do we think can we can we put OverWatch
ahead of our yeah yeah I think so I
genuinely think OverWatch is a better
game the way I like to think about
things is like which one would I be okay
with not existing anymore and like it's
valid the problem I think the game of
OverWatch is infinitely more fun
infinitely more interesting and in some
ways infinitely more skillful than
valoran valorin is a very slow choppy
stodgy game coming from someone who
played Counter-Strike as like their
competitive shooter for most their life
like there's a lot of things that it
does better the major thing is just
content like content is just like it's
nice to play a game that like it feels
like the developers like actually give
it also just doesn't feel the same as
Counter-Strike like as far as like being
the perfect competitive shooter Valor is
a lot more deliberate in everything you
do like like you're placing a smoke here
you're shooting an ability here I just
think like when it comes to watching it
as a competitive esport I'd much rather
be playing it